are animal foods really that bad during the helium stage for cancer and if it's grass-fed,
free-roamed meat. So yeah, there's again, you look on Instagram or Facebook or you do a search
on it, you're going to see even practitioners that will badmouth animal products big time in
that. Everybody needs to go on a vegan diet or you know, like we've talked about it. And that is just
false information. It's just wrong. Most of the people that are telling this have, you know,
don't have any substantiations to their claims. A lot of the practitioners that tell this,
of course, they happen to be vegans themselves. They've never had cancer and they've never treated
anybody with cancer. Again, I've said over and over for the last 25 years, every person
is different. Some people, animal products, can feed a cancer at a period of time, especially if
their cancer is heavily fed on amino acids at a period of time, but you know that that changes,
it can change. Cancer is always trying to find a fuel source. You know, what are the bad things about
eating animal products? What is a bad thing about eating meat? The answer is nothing's bad about
eating meat. So if you didn't have cancer, you should be eating meat. I am not in favor of
even a person without cancer being on a vegetarian or vegan type diet. There's a lot of people
that are doing it for different belief systems now. I don't think that's a healthy way to go.
You need protein with serious disease like cancer in order to develop lymphocytes
in order to create T cells and tumor-controlled white blood cells that are going to kill cancer.
So you need meat at some point in time. Now, again, everybody's different. What's the best way
to get meat? Yes, grass-fed, free-roamed, natural fish that's wild caught. Yes, there's inherent
problems with any food source whatsoever. So there isn't anything these days that is perfectly
clean. So if you know the farmer that you're getting your food from, it's going to be much better.
So, but again, every person's different getting tested is really important.